I love this act so much you should be
very proud of yourself
perfection absolutely brilliant I
thought it was incredible
grab your tissues get ready to dance and
be amazed America's Got Talent delivered
some seriously epic performances during
Tuesday's round of auditions we'll have
an opportunity to change the lives of
our families and bring them to America
meet Ukrainian dance group like balance
they left their home country for America
and a shot at a better life their
stunning performance left the judges in
awe and host Tyra Banks feeling some
type of way
but they're not the only squad that made
it through here's the just jerk dance
crew from South Korea
[Music]
[Applause]
other standouts include 25-year old
magician Tom London and a daredevil
clown that performed a death-defying
stunt but in typical AGT fashion they
saved the most heartfelt audition for
last I'm Evie Clare
how are you I'm 13 Evie got extremely
emotional crying as she told the judges
her dad was diagnosed with stage 4 colon
cancer last year they gave him a 5
percent chance to live and he's still
continued working and supporting our
family and so tonight I'm here to sing
with him no surprise here Evie is moving
on to the next round of competition
you